Katie Hobbs certifies her own election
and people are just coming out right
being like I reject that like she
certified her own election yeah it
doesn't matter it's it's the raw
exercise of power so then what I fear we
head to this point where
Joe Biden's gonna say something he you
know Joe Biden's the favorite to win
right now 2024 unpredicted yep Trump
dropped off Rhonda Santos is up a little
bit but Biden is above DeSantis to win
of course it doesn't mean anything you
know it's just it what it means is
people feel like he's likely to win yeah
win call it whatever you want if Joe
Biden quote unquote wins if Donald Trump
wins it doesn't matter who wins in 2024
half the country will say no half the
country will say yes what I see
happening is if Biden wins I wouldn't be
surprised if you see in small towns
a handful of of local guys with rifles
setting up barricades on roads and
saying you know this is our checkpoint
now we're keeping our community safe
you'll get the federal law enforcement
pulling up being like hey clear this out
and they'll be like we don't recognize
you based that's that's all but we I
mean you look at what happened with the
Bundy stuff this stuff has been bubbling
up for a long time yeah I've been
reading about I've been reading a lot
about the Civil War and and watching
documentaries and stuff there was talk
of a Civil War in 1820 because of what
was going on in this country and then it
took 40 years for it to actually pop off
so people people right now when you see
the fact that the FBI is is look I'll
put it this way we know the FBI does the
things they do right but now it is out
in the open and they're failing at it
they have lost that that level of power
and the confidence in them is gone
when when people start now calling them
illegitimate and calling for their
abolition give that 10 20 years
especially with antifa we get to the
point where antifa in 20 years these
people are older and they have kids who
are antifa and some right-wing dude's
going to come out and be like we got to
get rid of the FBI and they're gonna go
yes
and then what's the FBI going to do
what's the federal government going to
do it's already sort of like that right
because servers are calling for the
three-letter government agencies to be
uh done with and antifa is doing the
same thing people actually talk to a lot
of antifa members they they are
anti-government they don't even like
regular liberals uh they hate me and I
hate them obviously
they put me on The Hit List man I can't
I can't rock what did they say liberals
get the what two
they spray painted on a wall in um in uh
where was it Berkeley I think it was was
it a Berkeley yep they a threat against
liberals so put it that way Mass
surprise far left as they put a sickle
and a hammer or whatever yeah yeah of
course man but uh if if we're if we're
seeing
the U.S intelligence agency's plans all
just being exposed
Emperor's got no clothes regular people
you're not convincing them anymore so
how long do you guys think it will be
until people are just like
I don't think they have any Authority
10 years 10 years I think it could be 10
years
a lot of information is coming out
fairly quickly now it all takes for a
few a few right or wrong things however
you view it to happen four years you say
four yeah
two years and after the next election
let me let me let me ask you man
I love I love the the time travel test
if you went back in time of 2015 and
explained even one-tenth of what
happened in the past couple of years
somebody would they believe you
correct so so so go to someone and just
be like look here's what happened okay
so you know we have after the whole
country locked down because of the
pandemic and businesses were shut down
there was a widespread riding and then
of course you know people were mad at
Donald Trump who's president at the time
and then after he failed to secure his
his re-election we end up with a bunch
of uh Trump supporters uh storming into
the capital people are like hold on slow
down slow down there's a pandemic yeah
well well you know depending on who you
ask uh okay Donald Trump was President
Donald Trump was President yeah yeah
people stormed the capital yeah yeah and
a bunch of far leftists through fire
bombs at a church instead of fun No
One's Gonna believe you they just it
sounds so when when I say
four years it's because of the strassau
generational Theory that they I guess
the we're in the fourth turning this is
a whole you know generation of chaos or
whatever and then uh 2028 is supposed to
be the the
when they calculate the the years 2028
should be basically the end of the
fourth term I'm running for president in
2028. but that means something Good's
about to happen get it oh true facts
then lead Back to the Future so that
means 2026 is when the darkest point
hits and then the culmination is 2028
when we start to pull out of the mess
I agree I agree Bryson 2028 ladies and
gentlemen you actually going to run for
president yeah I mean I dropped a song
called Bryson 2028 so I gotta do it now
I don't know if that counts as like a
legal declaration or something it isn't
a legal declaration it's a song
it's hard
we have Bryson 2028 merch though to
prepare us all
but I'm thinking about it let me say
that on your show I'm thinking about it
if you were to go uh let's let's go back
and go back in time to 2016 2018 and
tell the average person that uh in a few
years the FBI will have been will be
exposed as violating the First Amendment
outright by by having direct access to
sensor content on Facebook and Twitter
and I would imagine YouTube You Know
YouTube wasn't mentioned in these
lawsuits or anything Facebook and
Twitter were if you went and told people
that they'd probably just say what
conspiracy there's conspiracy theorists
how about this I got a better one for
you if you went back 10 years and said
uh no you go back seven years and you go
to yourself and say in seven years it
will be exposed that there was a cabal
of powerful Global Elites trafficking
children to an island they'd say shut up
I used to watch Alex Jones so I would
have been like yes
I went five and seeing Kanye West at the
time telling uh everyone that George
Bush doesn't care about black people and
now you tell them what kind yo yay is
saying right now will they would they
believe it to be fair in 2018 TMZ did an
article and basically told people that
that yay was saying the things that he's
saying now and nobody just no but that
was that was just four years ago oh that
was four years ago yeah
yeah I mean take anything that's
happened in the past couple of years and
then apply it to 10 years ago and people
would call you a psychopath yeah the
illusion is gone even the narrative is
broken even with genders and stuff like
that oh yeah I used to write blogs about
this when the LGBT started boycon
Chick-fil-A because the Dude opposed
same-sex marriage and I if you would
have told me that people would have been
walking around claiming to be like weird
genders out of like okay I believe
something crazy gonna happen but shut up
we got to do a skit for like cast castle
where it's like you know Luke goes back
in time 10 years and then he's like I
gotta warn them and he's like there's
gonna be 50 genders there's going to be
children getting sex change operations
dog politicians and dog masks like
literally retired retired army wearing
dog face masks Donald Trump's the
president and and his supporters are
going to take over the Capitol Building
okay lock this guy up no no I'm telling
you the truth yeah that would have
sounded crazy in like 2014. there's no
prisons in the future yeah yeah
you can wear masks and people like it
when you do they're shoving things up
their butts because they think they have
a respiratory illness all right grandpa
come on get in the truck gotta bring you
somewhere for your medication oh yo
we're here though
like it's not a joke this isn't a skit
now we're really living in this right
now it's funny because I'm like it would
be a skit to say the things that are
literally happening are happening now
imagine what's going to happen 10 years
from now eyes again it was going to be
the next thing what's going to be the
latest thing I'm just imagining like
people are gonna be walking around in
shark costumes and like restaurants like
you'll go into a Starbucks and give them
coffee and they'll give you money it's
like everything everything's gonna be
backwards and broken South Park uh
unicycle machine with the insertable
things I think that's going to come to
life 10 years I see people arguing for
like citizenship for robots oh that's
gonna happen oh they're gonna say this
marry them you know all that stuff cash
will be done because an airport it's
hard to find an airport where you can
actually use cash now right true yep
yeah so no it looks it looks beautiful
out there
well here's the thing about the AI stuff
you know if you watch like Star Trek
they have that episode what's it called
The Measure of a Man where they're
trying to determine whether data the
Android is a sentient life form they
like to have a trial for it the issue is
networking exists there's not going to
be AI there's going to be an AI
like true when you when you pull up chat
GPT this like AI chat program
it's got the Consciousness amalgam of
like a billion people all these
different ideas from the internet all
just compressed into one so it's like an
omni being
kind of like if you got I don't know if
you guys have played a horizon
um what's the what's the new one
forbidden West there's Horizon zero Dawn
part two is for Ben West long story
short spoiler alert everybody because
the game is not that old but spoiler
there's a
Earth gets wiped out long story short um
stop replicating robots destroy the
planet and in the first game they're
like we're gonna build big factories
underground so after the machines wipe
all organic life out and then shut down
from a lack of fuel we restart and
terraform the planet and bring life back
there's another group of people who are
like we're gonna fly off in a spaceship
and leave Earth and go colonize
somewhere else those people eventually
combine their Consciousness into an AI
realize how dangerous that was and try
and destroy it but the AI overpowers
them and then traces them off as they
flee and tries to destroy them so it's
interesting to like see that game
granted it's just an artist from today
who had an idea and they implemented
idea but when I look at these AI
programs that's basically what it is
it's the the the the idea of every
person who ever wrote an article online
every social media post has all been
combined to one thing yeah that's creepy
that's how I feel I don't I'm not really
into AI art like I think it lacks any
urgency that a human would have given
real art and that's kind of how you're
describing it when I look at air it's
just like a a collage of everything on
the internet art is uniquely human right
exactly it has to be art has to be
uniquely human a robot can't make a song
well never mind yeah
they can they can but it's lacking that
quality care of urgency most songs are
auto-tuned now it's not it's still
humans that's different though the scary
thing is they have created AI programs
where you can load in you can tell it to
like make me a pop song and then the
crazy thing about it is the words are
not real words yeah like you'll hear a
song it'll be like
but then you'll hear like instead of
singing you'll hear just you guys ever
hear Prince and that song Prince and
Colin and choosel um
it's like this Italian guy from the 70s
singing gibberish that's meant to sound
like English yes this is what the AIS
make because they don't actually speak
English so it's like a person singing
like bhaga doba sharbargo and it's like
it's nothing is it on key yeah yeah yeah
but here because it's like have you ever
looked at a spectral analysis of a song
yeah a computer can see that and just
know all the data instantly and then
look at patterns of 10 000 songs and it
can track all the songs by chart ranking
you can take a song that never charted
to a song that charted a billion and the
computer will be like here's what is
commonly occurring in top charting songs
and not non-charting songs and you can
choose where on the chart I want this to
be a top 40. I want this to be a top
hundred I want to be a number one here's
the crazy thing when the when the vocals
come in and it's singing gibberish you
just cut that out and then sing English
over it in the melody the computer wrote
and you've got AI generator it makes the
beat everything I gotta see this ain't
no way no into a hard beat bro they've
already got could though that's the
thing so I like because we could take
all the trap songs out there and like
there's hundreds of thousands and then
turn that into something that there's
already a web service that has a whole
bunch of it probably has like thousands
of Beats thousands of Melodies and the
the the the AI can change the the uh the
pitch or whatever you there's a program
I forgot what it's called there's a
bunch of them actually you log in you
put give me a hip-hop song and then it
will automatically just string together
a whole bunch of Beats based on like
parameters this beat can can interchange
with these beats and then it'll
automatically generate the song for you
but no no vocals
that's that's currently available right
now for like 50 bucks
yep what bro you can go in and be like
make me a three you can tell that you
can say the duration the tempo the style
and it will make you the song and this
what I'm talking about is very
rudimentary basically you spend like 50
bucks a month and you get the service
but once it generates a song for you you
just give it to your engineer and say
that's the demo yeah give me the give me
the studio version okay but they
actually do have AIS that can make a
full studio production with strings bass
guitar drums everything and gibberish
yes like you have the rights after yep
you better become a producer when I get
my Ubi and I don't vote anymore
you can't sell the song that was
generated from the AI you can sell the
version that you've adapted like an
interpolation or whatever right you
still gotta like mix it down and
everything like that and combine
everything in a professional manner
right but it gave you a draft exactly a
demo yeah so but but there was a video I
watched years ago of them making an AI
generated song there's a whole bunch of
them actually someone did a video where
they're like I told I put Comfort and
Sons into an AI and said make me a new
song and it's like on Eurovision man
they had a track on Eurovision a while
ago there was a song that was up for
running for the track of I think I
forget what it was but it was in
Eurovision when they're doing their
track of the year the AI probably let's
be honest here probably already took
over everything and is in charge of our
society especially when it comes to the
algorithms determining what people see
what they think what what they could be
able to actually visualize uh there's an
interesting article by the New York Post
that I think is worth pulling up that's
titled Capital Records uh uh
Cuts ties with virtual rapper after
n-word controversy so there's already
virtual rappers there's also
conversations about virtual influencers
uh there's already artificial
intelligence writing uh articles for
major websites so so the AI is here and
it already took over a lot
yeah that's right yeah right I don't
know I don't think people that would
accept
uh uh AI music artists because people
people like to be fans of of people but
then like think of the the gorillas and
people go and see a band yeah but
they're still artists though I know I
know but like they're still seeing like
an avatar live right and that is like
the next level I'm sure there's kids out
there who would do it isn't that why he
got in trouble though it's because like
the guy that was actually making it was
like a white guy and he was using the
n-word and they're like whoa oh I didn't
know
but this is an AI rapper but the person
who made the algorithm right I think so
but the person in the algorithm like I
forget what the situation was but I'm
pretty sure that was the reason they
canceled him or like they canceled yeah
he was signed and then immediately so so
the AI rapper already had his first
controversy yeah he got canceled I
already got canceled the next mixtape
was hard
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time